Penicillin.
It was discovered totally by accident.
In 1928, Scottish scientist Alexander Fleming...
...left his lab to go on vacation without cleaning up.
When he came back,...
...he found mold had developed on a contaminated sample of staphylococci.
Remarkably, the molds had killed the surrounding bacteria.
He decided to name the substance released from the mold "penicillin."
But what is penicillin exactly?
It is an antibiotic that fights bacteria...
...by stopping the cell wall from renewing during growth.
This weakens the cell wall until it bursts, killing the bacteria.
It wasn't until the 1940s that America and Britain...
...funded the mass production of penicillin.
Hailed as a miracle drug that saved countless lives during World War II,...
...it allowed the Allies to patch up a soldier...
...and have them ready to fight again in a matter of weeks.